giảng viên hướng dẫn của em là thầy Kiều
Đức Hạnh nhóm em với đề tài là hệ thống
quản lý học viện cho phép
do bọn em chọn đề tài này bởi vì hệ
thống hiện hành của nhà trường thì vẫn
còn sơ sài và thủ công là hầu như là chủ
chủ yếu là nhập bằng Word và Excel thì
nên là tầm một phần mềm chuyên dụng vì
trường cũng là trường công nghệ thông
tin
kiểu cũng nên áp dụng công nghệ và để tự
tạo thành nhu cầu ngày càng lớn của học
viện cũng như là 5 độ chính xác và hiệu
quả khi mà
quản lý sinh viên cũng như nhập liệu
quan trọng nhất vẫn là dán công việc cho
cán bộ cũng như là tăng độ chính xác và
không tránh tình trạng chậm trễ và
cập nhật tình trạng của sinh viên cũng
như là tình trạng giảng dạy của giảng
viên
ngôn ngữ lập trình PSP là một cửa bắc em
kênh Word lauriel và Kenwood
em cho vào rất là ổn Nó là của nó là
tuyên bố TP và cơ sở dữ liệu là máy fpl
về hệ thống điện thành thì chưa xài thủ
công quản lý khó khăn và độ chính xác
thì sẽ
không quản lý của chính xác của các
chính xác sẽ không cao
diện với người dùng dễ thao tác và
phương thức với nhiều kích cỡ màn hình
cụ thể là có thể dùng trên điện thoại về
nghiệp vụ thì là dễ sử dụng cũng như là
chính xác
có những tính năng thì sẽ tự động về bảo
mật thì sẽ yêu cầu bảo mật cao và bọn em
có làm là nếu mà đăng nhập sai quá nhiều
lần sẽ khóa tài khoản về phần cứng thì
cho bạn là thiết bị nào vào truy cập
được mạng để dùng được
và giải pháp thì gọi em chọn là ngôn ngữ
pp là ngôn ngữ bắt em Quyên góp lauriel
áp dụng
cả Facebook đút sát làm giao diện và
template
chuyên dụng để quản lý
an ninh LV và kết hợp thêm vài thư viện
nữa về ram Switch
các đối tượng sử dụng của em sẽ là giáo
viên giáo vụ kế toán và sinh viên
và đây là đây là qua về phần cơ sở dữ
liệu của Việt Nam điểm danh của giáo
viên thì giáo viên sẽ đăng nhập vào điểm
like
trên phần mềm
Đây là cơ sở dữ liệu về quản lý của tạp
vụ và vụ sở hữu rất nhiều cái ví dụ như
chương trình chương trình đào tạo môn
học của sinh viên giảng viên
nhưng mà ở bên học viện mình thì nó còn
sợ khác biệt và nó có vụ chuyển điện
chuyển điện sang K bằng nghề thế nên là
phần mềm sẽ tự động làm việc đấy
nó vụ phân công giảng dạy thì sẽ phân
công cho giáo viên giảng dạy theo lớp và
cho môn khi mà giảm giảng viên đăng nhập
thì sẽ chỉ hiển thị môn và lớp mà mình
đã được phân công
và đó vụ có phần tính công giảng dạy
nghĩa là sau mỗi tháng giảm viêm điểm
danh xong và vũ sẽ tổng kết lại số giờ
mà giảng viên đã giảng dạy trong tràn
đầy để thành công
và đây là một tính năng nên cảm thấy rất
hay và lập danh sách thi nó yêu cầu được
chính xác bởi vì
mình đã nhập điểm danh cho sinh viên rồi
thì mình sẽ lấy được những ai đủ điều
kiện để được chi và hiển thị ra Danh
sách đề xuất những bạn nào đã bị trượt
đã bị trượt một ngày của lớp khác hoặc
là những bạn học lại thì sẽ hiển thị ra
đề xuất
chứ không phải là thủ công nhớ
và phần của phần kế toán thì sẽ hiển thị
ra
sẽ có tính năng là kiểm tra xác nhận
thành công của giảng viên giảng viên sẽ
được giáo hội
đầu tiên là giảm bụng sẽ
làm cái trẻ con để cho giảng viên xác
nhận xem có đúng là tháng vừa rồi đã dạy
người này tiếng và kể toàn sẽ vào xem để
mà thành công
sinh viên Tra cứu điểm thi cái tính năng
này là em làm để cho sinh viên có thể tự
cho quý vị khi mình qua
tên và số điện thoại để xác thực sinh
viên đấy rồi sẽ hiển thị bảng điểm của
sinh viên đấy
nhưng khi bạn có xem chi tiết và chi
tiêu các bạn sinh viên tại sao mình phải
có văn bản chương trình tìm kiếm cái
điểm danh thì chỉ có sinh viên bằng cái
việc thay đổi còn
môn học đầu tiên lớp và này nuôi nổi
trong những video trở lên
hiển thị chiều tạo lớn sinh viên và đơn
vị về phần Xóa thì tên là em đã có thể
đi về đi cho học viện tàu và những cái
nghĩa quan trọng lên để chúng mình có
thể tăng tốc
trên thủ công Xin mời bạn về phần dịch
về vấn hiệu quả thì khi bắt đầu khi bắt
đầu học mới thì giáo dục có thể dùng
tính năng thêm đồ họa để
tiện cho đến lượt Bảo Chung Hồng Kông
thì
theo như hóa chất thì có một hai lớp
có bao gồm 4 nước lập trình và cả nước
và chính bản thì
chúng ta còn đang
thêm vào cái hệ thống có thể tạo điểm
nhấn xoay được thì mình
mình
chìm được thì khi đầy vào trong cái hệ
thống này thì nó có kiểm soát được sự
thật đấy
bây giờ nếu mà em em lại chắc chắn là sẽ
chụp thế nên là nó sẽ báo lỗi vậy
[âm nhạc]
nhập bên mình
đúng không
tra cứu sinh viên có thể tận tra cứu
tình trạng đi học của bản thân ví dụ là
đã nghỉ tỉ lệ nỉ mình là bao nhiêu và đã
bình luận đã vượt kiểu ngưỡng là học lại
thì lại trường
[âm nhạc]
Y học của chúng ta cũng chẳng cần biết
nó hôn
làm thì hai
đoạn 12,5
đúng không
học kỳ mà được học trong môn nào Môn lại
có thể là lớp này cộng với lớp Kiên
rồi nếu mà tính thời gian sau đó anh học
được 20 môn rồi
[âm nhạc]
tình trạng cho từng môn cho từng lớp làm
những môn Toán học và những môn đã kết
thúc thì ở bên thì anh chỉ cần sửa đấy
là kiểu sẽ chỉ định vị những môn đã học
để học nhưng mà nhưng thực ra là em làm
việc năm này thì lúc đầu là sẽ hiển thị
mỗi một lớp thì sẽ chỉ học tầm 21 môn
thế nên là và đây là những cái hiển thị
ra những môn mà đã học Thế nên là mình
em nghĩ là nó không phải là nhiều lắm
[âm nhạc]
Sơn là tôi bị giả sử như học tập đúng
không
hiển thị làm gì ta nhìn sẽ giống lên
ở đây là có ở đây thì em mới làm được
cái mỗi lọc được một cái sinh viên đang
đang học còn sinh viên và kết thúc video
là em có ở đây anh sẽ demo và bắt đầu từ
giáo viên điểm danh
tiếng Anh sẽ hiển thị ra thủ môn và giáo
viên đề chính trị phân công còn lớp thôi
đây sẽ hiển thị ra thời lượng môn học
hành động thì anh xin lập trình nó sẽ
hiển thị được và hiển thị là thời lượng
đã dạy cắm trước đây nữa
còn lại của môn này
viên người ta sẽ nhận được thông tin về
mình thì
[âm nhạc]
mua chọn những lớp học môn đấy mà giáo
viên đã được phân công rồi
và đây sẽ hiển thị là thời lượng học môn
đấy thời lượng đã dạy thắng trước tháng
này và thời lượng còn lại
ở đây
và em em chỉ cho phép là điểm danh trong
ngày và trong giờ đấy không Cho mình chữ
danh vào ngày khác hoặc là buổi khác và
ở đây Còn nút ấn thì nó sẽ hiển thị ra
luôn độ đây cập nhật tức là giáo viên
đến đi vào nhà mình nên đứng dậy xong mà
không vào thế này thì
không được sớm hơn giờ bắt đầu và không
được muộn hơn giờ kết thúc 30 phút nhé
làm thế để sau chuyển danh nó chuẩn đúng
không
khi điểm danh đến không được gặp lại cái
đấy thì phải tự liên hệ với giá bộ bởi
vì nó liên quan đến việc tính công
vừa nãy bạn đã thành công cho
giáo viên ạ thì mình sẽ hiển thị hiển
thị ra những khóa mà đã được điểm danh
thì download về Việt Nam một thời điểm
danh trong tháng đấy và ví dụ là đây
giáo viên ở đây sẽ có cái phần xác nhận
vừa nãy em nói là kiểu đầu tiên là mình
sẽ làm thành công cho rằng các bước là
giảm là giảm đi điểm danh xong Hồi Giáo
hội sẽ vào xem điểm danh Nếu mà thấy
đúng thì sẽ Ấn Nút cập nhật ở đây để
giáo viên xác nhận lại một lần nữa là
làm kiểu Tháng trước đã dạy đúng giờ như
thế xong ngồi kế toán xong rồi kế toán
mới có thể hiển thị ra cái bảng số tờ mà
giáo viên đã dạy
ấn cập nhật ở đây có cả cập nhật và in
và cập nhật và gửi mail Gửi mail cho vào
mịn cho dòng điện ở đây anh có thể thay
đổi giáo viên và gửi cho giao diện lựa
chọn
nãy nói là sẽ lập lập danh sách khi ly
dựa trên điểm danh của sinh viên là điểm
danh muôn đời em đã đủ điều kiện để khi
em chưa và ngoài ra là sẽ hiển thị ví dụ
là đây em sẽ chọn
khóa chọn lớp chọn bộ môn đấy sẽ hiển
thị sẽ có bạn bị cấm thi và ở dưới đề
xuất thì sẽ Anh chị gần bên bạn ở lớp
khác là kiểu ví dụ bạn lớp khác bạn bị
cấm thi hoặc là bị học bị điểm 10 Năm
Nghĩa phải thi lại thì sẽ hiển thị ở
dưới
và khi em ấn cập nhập thì sẽ tự động gửi
mail tất cả sinh viên đấy cũng như là
giảng viên được chọn ở đây rằng nguyên
con Chi ạ Và còn phần nữa để chăm sóc
sinh viên thì em có làm cái thông báo
thông báo ở đây sẽ thông báo lên cả
Gmail và đồng thời Đăng lên cả Facebook
các nhóm của một lớp đã được chọn ở đây
sẽ còn thêm phần nữa là phần senting
hình chuyên cần ví dụ là em muốn xem và
cả 8 có những bạn nghỉ ừ 20 thủ tục số
1.000 từ 20% đến 40% thôi hoặc là đến
100% thì nó sẽ nhiều hơn Đây chính là nó
sẽ hiển thị
những cái bạn mà Kiểu nghỉ quá nhiều ấy
ạ Mình sẽ có ấn gửi thông báo để nhắc
nhở các bạn đấy để các bạn đi học đầy đủ
đây là sẽ gửi email
chatbot Messenger của Facebook đang kết
nối rồi
gửi mail trong em chưa làm được Mình
đang chăm sóc cho phụ huynh sinh viên
bởi vì phần cũng chưa có email của cấu
hình
phát triển phần mềm để em định làm tính
năng là kiểu sẽ nhận diện khuôn mặt Bởi
vì em đã tìm được cái bida để mà theo
kiểu
nhận diện theo khuôn mặt rồi thì làm thế
nào điểm danh bằng hình ảnh thì nó sẽ có
gì đó hấp dẫn hơn
truy cập vào trang web bằng trình duyệt
thì nó đến nghĩa vụ hơn
anh chị nhé
nhất là hạn chế về màn hình đúng không ạ
sau đó là chúng ta nhìn nhận điện trong
này em có rất nhiều chức năng thì cái
đầu tiên trước khi đã dành cho cô giáo
cho câu hỏi thì qua bên thì phải cho em
ấy chỉ có một ngày mới ấn tượng đầu tiên
ấy là bây giờ mình phải kê khai và các
bạn nếp ở thực hiện
có sử dụng
các bạn có nghe cái khoảng hồi phục lại
của cái người mà người ta sử dụng hệ
thống của em hơn trong đấy Em nói là em
đã được đưa vào
nhưng mà em đã khắc phục và đạt hoặc
thân thiện hơn thì bộ dạng như là vừa
nãy nói một điểm danh của giáo viên ạ
thì giáo viên đôi khi là quên mất mình
đã điểm danh rồi thì bây giờ không thể
tin ngay trên đầu và tương tự thế cho
vào bụng em quên thì chưa nói nên dùng
tính năng nữa đó là một tính năng giảm
nhiệt kế hoạt động của người dùng thì
đóng góp đối với quê mình đã gửi mẹo rồi
thì
bảng ngay ở dưới sẽ bật sẽ hiển thị
đẹp
Hãy hiển thị ra và 6 phút đấy đã đã gửi
mail rồi hẹn có thể tìm kiếm ở ngay đây
mình cần độ chính xác cao mà không thể
spam Neo hay các thứ được
đẹp đang xem
thực tế của nó Tức là mình lấy từ một
câu hỏi sau sạch sẽ phòng mình đã yêu
đời chế độ nó tất nhiên là trong quá
trình sử dụng thì nó sẽ có những cái
phần lũy nhiều trở ngại khi ta hiểu rằng
là nó đến một cái bài toán thì bao giờ
có vậy chứ nếu em xây dựng cái đinh của
thầy thường của Thanh Yến
đều là đầu tiên với một cái sản phẩm cho
đánh giá là cái phần trăm là
[âm nhạc]
các bạn thiết kế cơ thể như thế này thì
em có thể bị một lúc tới cái cách mà em
thiết kế như vậy em muốn tới nhóm người
dùng hoặc là em có thể hướng tới các cái
giao dịch đúng không
ạ
thì có thể là rất là khó từ thời gian
đầu đối với bức tường hả Hay đi học sinh
chẳng hạn
đúng không Tức là khi các bạn sẽ thấy
đây này tất nhiên là em có một cái thì
đến đây Các bạn cứ điều thứ ba Các bạn
báo cáo thì có một cái nữa thì cô làm
ban đầu và với cái yêu cầu của chúng ta
thì không yêu cầu các bạn phải tức là
trẻ cần cái người phân tích
hoàn hảo đúng không
em chia làm mấy em thiết kế xây dựng
em đầu tiên là chính xác là đầu tiên là
bọn em phải tạo chương trình đào tạo bên
wkfast được tạo nên chương trình đào tạo
thành camera
liên kết với nhau xong rồi nhập môn của
từng chi như là bạn rồi giới hạn ánh xạ
Môn đấy môn bên cạnh Becamex cho mình
người mua bên trong làm việc và xong rồi
đỏ đúng không như vậy em có cái mã môn
này
mã môn của mình là tết mà mã môn của hoa
đồng nghề trên cái chương trình đào tạo
mà em yêu của internet
[âm nhạc]
đúng không Nhưng mà
môi chẳng hạn
đúng không Thế thì cái mã đấy rồi đó
[âm nhạc]
cái điểm nó chuyển đấy cái việc mà anh
chị được chị chuyên nghiệp thì em cũng
có hai bạn của riêng là bằng sự nghiệp
bks và bảng điểm các bạn về và Nhưng mà
em nhớ em để cho nó tự động theo kiểu là
đến cuối năm học thì em về chính xác là
kết thúc hoặc tiếp tục nông nghiệp thì
người cần truyền điểm đúng không ạ
xong rồi bấm nút trừ điểm xong rồi thì
sẽ ước lượng những môn Anh em bks sẽ
được kiểm điểm giao lưu một cái cảm biến
từ bảng điểm là môn cái cà cách sang
bảng điểm toàn diện
nó chưa có tìm mà như em nói là thế này
rất môn đúng không
Ví dụ như là theo minh bảo hiểm thì muốn
lên cái bảo hiểm cuối cùng bọn em được
bằng có phải thế thì bọn em sẽ có cái
phiên bản chung là theo khoa học thì học
kỳ này là bên khóa học phần môn Thế thì
với lời của cô ấy thì nó tương ứng với
7,5 nào
[âm nhạc]
này ở bên em 10 môn nhưng mà thật ra thì
nó chỉ lại chỉ cần chuyển sang môi sau
những thế thôi
của con là người có thể sang để phân
biệt với kết quả
thì sẽ chỉ truyền những môn có liên kết
và có điện thì là một chuyện
thì trong trong cái chương trình cho đại
lý nó còn có cái môn học nhé mã môn này
tên luôn này muốn lấy được học giỏi Từ
nào
nhiều người
Muốn học đúng rồi nhưng mà nó còn gì hết
học thì không không bị làm vợ bởi vì em
em làm cái tính năng này là để cho tiện
cho người dùng
kiểu bớt phải kiểu biết nhiều bài toán
rồi thì đôi khi mà dùng cũng không hẳn
là hiểu lắm em ạ chỉ có bấm nút ở đây
thì thế nên là em sẽ làm thực phẩm hết
Nhưng mà nếu mà thêm vài cái tùy chọn
thì người dùng có thể họ thao tác thế
này em làm tự động để gửi Bởi vì lúc đầu
em nhớ Nhầm là nó là kết thúc khóa học
thì sẽ chuyển điểm cùng một loạt công để
mà đi bằng cấp trung thu cái gì
[âm nhạc]
và không cơ sở dữ liệu em có biết là bạn
này là bạn em đi ban từ đâu xuống không
bạn từ năm nào bạn xuống là
không lưu thời gian cụ thể nó không
Không còn lựa thời gian thì mình phải
rất tiếc
[âm nhạc]
nhưng mà thực ra là nếu mà em có làm
tính năng miễn phí hoạt động đấy ạ thì
nếu mà tra theo mã mạng mã sinh viên bảo
vệ tổ trại sẽ ra và bảo vệ đã được thay
đổi về tình trạng đó là chúng ta nên nói
gì
bây giờ
mã hóa mật khẩu
có thể cho biết
được
[âm nhạc]
giới thiệu cái hàng
sẵn rồi
tự một cách chỉnh tần số và theo đúng độ
dài thì nhất định
và mã hóa này có thể mã hóa cho file nữa
thì mình sử dụng
an toàn khủng long
Bởi vì tao với em nó hỗ trợ là FBI hỗ
trợ chống những cái viên restaurant
[âm nhạc]
em nghĩ ở cái việc mã hóa này cốt là để
cho những sự ai đó vào được à Thằng
database của mình chứ không phải thông
qua trang web ví dụ vào
ảnh hưởng bằng server ấy hẳn sẽ không
thì sẽ không làm được
[âm nhạc]